i have no idea what's going on what is
going on
there was a technology that was better
than green screen this movie came out
15 years ago those jets look so nice and
shiny
these are bad visual effects yeah those
are you should feel bad about them
i'm so confused
thanks to lgtv for sponsoring this video
all the clips are watching today are
being viewed on an
lg nano cell tv so stick around to the
end to learn about what makes this tv
special
hey welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artists react we've had a
bunch of stunt friends in here for the
past couple weeks
hey no more stunt man we want the
computer man back
yeah that's right that's what i was
saying too the last few weeks
but we're back with some visual effects
artists react today we got some pretty
fascinating stuff
one in particular is pretty nuts because
did you guys know that there was a
technology that was
arguably better than green screen that
was invented back in 1950
so if you want to see how that works and
more stay tuned
all right let's jump in commence
oh yes oh jesus christ
all right so stephen king wrote a series
of short stories the langoliers was one
of them the premise is this
they're flying an airplane and it flies
through a rip in space
what they proceed to land at an airport
in the alternate reality
because they've accidentally traveled to
a parallel dimension
the langoliers are coming there's this
parallel dimensional alien race called
the langoliers
whose job it is to dispose of these old
dimensions
and they must get back to theirs before
they get consumed
wait the langeliers are the meatballs
yes dude mama
freaking mia oh my god daddy no
except go away please make them go away
oh no don't need me this movie's three
hours long
i can't act for this long
get out of here whoa
that was cool okay i don't care what
either of you say them crunching through
the ground like that i liked that
that was sweet it leaves behind like
where the two pieces were
together like there's actually some some
good detail there
all i have to say about the meatballs is
this there's some very very basic things
they could have done to make them look
better
in the year 1995 the year 1995 well like
what
making sure the image quality of your cg
isn't like light years ahead of the
image quality
of your video they probably shot this in
like 16 millimeter films you know it's
not
the highest res it's not super crisp per
se and you can really see like
the issue there with like how crisp the
cg is and how dark the shadows are
i think two things first off horrible
animation
i see keyframes i don't see like physics
so to speak
that's the first huge problem the second
one is we have a scene
with a bunch of interdimensional
monsters like where is the scariest
place
to shoot that what's the scariest
setting and let's do
bright overcast daylight on a completely
beige
environment and it's like well you're
screwed
there's nothing to obscure the creatures
in the environment the lighting doesn't
play towards the poor rendering
it's poor filmmaking going into it what
would have made this better is generally
the people shooting the effects
understanding the process that they're
shooting shots that can help the effects
you know
yeah but how many people really even
understood any of this 25 years ago
this came out just a couple years after
jurassic park like the number of people
who probably knew how to do this better
are very small and they probably just
weren't able to afford them for this
piece
because they probably had a tiny budget
to begin with i'm just saying
cut an hour off the movie and use the
thousands and thousands of dollars that
would have taken the film that extra
hour
this is back in the day when it was only
tv and at a certain point you just need
to fill time
i think that's really what this was yeah
they were just filling time they're like
what of our thousands of stephen king
properties
is worth making today
so i was recently reminded about a movie
called stealth by this website called
beforesandafters.com if you want to dive
more into how visual effects and stuff
like that work that's a fantastic
resource and website to check out
so the movie stealth basically is around
these three
super pro fighter pilots they have these
really cool like
navy stealth jets that are really fast
and then they have to contend with an ai
who's going to trick their gerbs
the movie itself isn't very good but the
effects are top
class from digital domain they're very
excellently done they pioneered a whole
bunch of
stuff for this movie and it really shows
this looks great this is right when like
physically based rendering starting to
become a thing it's like
not even quite there yet it's like just
artists at the top of the game
understanding the light
yeah this movie came out 15 years ago
those jets look so nice and shiny
and all of this is completely computer
generated there are no photographic
plates here the background is all
computer generated
back then like it was very very very
hard to do clouds what do you do
for clouds it's like usually you're
sitting there like all right i'll take a
2d image
make a background it's like well i gotta
move through them it's like well
are you just gonna put a bunch of cards
in the scene like little 2d
sprites this was a very unique problem
for the vfx team here because there are
tons of clouds
rendered everywhere for them to go
through they ended up having to generate
we're talking dozens and dozens of
square miles worth of just
clouds and that meant a lot and lot of
data we're talking
hundreds of gigabytes worth of data and
they had to come up with a special
workflow
just to process all the clouds we're
talking like low resolution clouds off
in the distant background
and then medium range clouds that
they're actually flying through those
were the high res ones and that combined
with you know the really high resolution
planes flying through them and the
camera flying through at really high
speeds
all of that to just give a sense of
speed going through everything
but the thing that was surprising to me
is the fact that
the cockpits are glass the helmet visors
are glass
and how do you film glass without having
the reflections of the crew
of the camera appear in the shot and the
answer is you just do it digitally and
so
there's a moment when django unchained
here he actually like knocks on his
helmet
but he's just miming it he's just kind
of like and you can kind of see his
floaty hand but they add the sound
effect of like
that's how you do it i to do a quick
shout out we're talking about stealth
to the best explosion ever committed to
film
hell yeah okay that is pretty sweet so
those people are actually there
and those trucks are actually like
flipping amazing yeah christian just
muttered jesus under his breath back
there
so amazing and like the fake cars if you
look closely you can see it's just like
canvas over uh pipe frames
this is magic this is something special
right here
so stealth was actually recommended to
me in a comment and you're totally right
we had to talk about it thank you for
that comment if you have other clips
that you think we should watch leave a
comment down below
what's happening to me wait is this the
old twin peaks or the new twin
no it's the old as we can see it's the
elderly twin peaks
oh getting tiny wait he's shrinking
whoa whoa wait what just a jump cut to
his head turning into black smoke
okay is he a snitch did he turn into the
snitch
ooh that tracking or whatever was going
on there
what the [ __ ] what that
[Music]
i'm so confused
it feels like very authentic to like the
visual effects of the time when the
series originally came out
do you feel like those visual effects
were good or bad
the thing is i make an argument here
that david lynch didn't want
any realism whatsoever he just won the
collagi
basic cutout element feeling style of
the effect so it's just imagery
it just cuts to it it just moves it just
does its thing no it these are bad
visual effects yeah those are
you feel bad about them the hand
shrinking i don't know how they did that
it kind of looked like it was a
practical thing it kind of looked like
they were shrinking it but then the ring
fell off
see that looks very good and i have no
idea what's going on there but then his
head
literally just pops away and then this
like golden orb
is just moving around with no motion
blur and really hard
sharp keyframes and the the highlight is
just as bright on it when it's in the
smoke versus when it's out yeah
and then this thing is literally just
the final image here
but it's stretched vertically so you're
having like all these stretch
stretched pixels and then it pops to a
different element as it starts to evolve
and move
i have no idea what's going on what is
going on every time i think it gets
it's done being ridiculous it gets more
ridiculous and confusing
and maybe that's the point did david
lynch actually do this shot
i i would not be surprised if david
lynch did those effects himself
it's more abstract and subjective i
guess but now i feel like
i'm just making excuses i mean we all
kind of are this is like an art gallery
by the way where everyone's right
every every one of these opinions is 100
correct i'm all down for like weird
janky
crazy visual stuff but like you know as
my art teacher said when i submitted a
half-assed drawing
if you're intentionally trying to do
something that doesn't look good you
need to make sure it's really
intentional so it doesn't feel like a
mistake
i mean if it's like if the goal is to go
hey look at this weird thing and you're
like
this is we this it's weird he did it
he got us
what's up guys today's opposite day hit
unsubscribe
dislike the video flag others comments
i know what you're not doing right now
[Music]
wait a second this movie was made before
computers
this these are visual effects visual
effects are designed with
pcs that's not true the visual and
visual effects means that you're using
optical printers
sorry i'm distracted by the fact that
this dude has like pants with the
crotch down in his ankles these way that
is time for joggers man
is the background the cartoon as well
was it painted on a wall it looks like
it might be a mural and they're on a
little sound stage
that background was not there and they
thought okay
in star wars you can tell when they're
on a fake background but this is from
1964 and you can't tell that background
was literally filmed
take a look at mary poppins hat what's
special about that hat
it's transparent it's transparent
transparent
if somebody hires me to do vfx
supervision and they're like all right
we're gonna have this person from a
green screen
they have all this transparent like lace
i'd be like no
don't do it this is a 1964. how do you
get
transparency without a computer alright
so
like okay star wars you make black and
white mats on a piece of film
and then you use the white layer to
basically
expose the light onto the part of the
image that you want to keep we talked a
lot about this in our episode talking
about the original star wars movies
because they did all of these effects
using just optical
separation of light and stuff like that
if you want to find out more information
check out that episode
so in star wars they filmed their shifts
on a blue screen but the thing about
that niko is that you're getting a very
distinct
black or white mat there's no
transparency in between
yes 100 also nobody can wear blue
in this scene he has a blue tie he has
blue socks and the ground is green
what color could they use every color is
in this frame
that m effort is sprinkling salt
he's sprinkling salt they're using
sodium vapor lights
and sodium vapor lights emit light
specifically on only one part of the
electromagnetic spectrum so they're
very strict that's right yeah okay
this is just sodium vapor wash on the
background and they have uh they have a
technique color camera so back in the
day technicolor cameras ran three strips
of film
one strip of black and white filmed red
one stripper black and white film for
green and one strip of black and white
film blue
you can combine that and get colors they
took one of those cameras they modified
it to only have two strips
and they have a prism and the prism
splits off
the wavelength of sodium vapor light to
one film roll
and then everything else all the rest of
the light goes to another film roll
so in the moment when they're rolling
the shot there's two pieces of film
one that's getting the shot and one
that's getting a perfect black and white
mask with transparency of the background
because it's only exposing to a certain
wavelength
so it's the perfect split because the
light is still
physically being split and like selected
that's so complicated
it is it's basically a perfect map
before
you even post-process it it seems too
good to be true
why are we not still using this
technology today yeah really what gives
so the reason is they basically invented
this one-off
magical device like it's the closest
thing you could get to magic because
they were never able to replicate the
prisons
so you've seen the camera the prism the
little heart of the camera
is a one-of-a-kind piece it's like a
lifesaver they have a one-of-a-kind
crystal gem in the middle of this camera
right here wouldn't mean one
one you just can't there's no such thing
as just making one of something
how can we not recreate this we're
definitely dealing with off-world
technology
look if anyone knows where that crystal
power is and has a map
basically our next episode will be
tracking it down and shooting something
with it
all right so after filming this episode
there's one thing i've been thinking
about this entire time looking at this
tv
and that's the fact that if you play
smash bros my character is going to be
about as big as me
so let's go get a gaming real quick
because i've been itching to do that
here let me get first place real quick
so big thanks to lg for sponsoring this
episode
this is the new lg nano cell this is an
86 inch television it is
a work of art so i'm gonna tell you all
about what makes this tv special
while i kick all their butts now this tv
offers something called pure color
technology which uses lg's
nano cell filters to give you the most
vibrant color
possible also another great thing about
this tv is they offer 4k
up to 86 inches and 8k up to 75 inches
that's right
you can get your own 8k television on
top of that they have a bunch of great
gaming modes
we make use of all the time here in the
office there's a low latency one
millisecond of leg only mode for the tv
which is
awesome everything i could ever want in
tv plus they have freesync
variable refresh rate all that good
stuff and of course a giant size that
your smash character is at least as big
as an action figure
so excuse me for a second here while i
win this game
so as you can see lg delivers superior
gaming technology and immersive
experience
click the link in the description below
and click the where to buy button to see
retail price once again today thanks to
lg for sponsoring this series
and you know what i personally actually
love these televisions i own one myself
they're great check them out did that
just happen
did that just happen well it's always a
good time sitting down with buddies and
looking at some cool vfx
next week we have a swordmaster coming
in to show us all the cool things about
sword choreography on film that's gonna
be super cool so
tune in for that episode